pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
there's nothing with clouds out there
pilot to Bombardier
greetings [ __ ] uncle Joey him
it's Friday the 16th 15th whatever the
[ __ ] it is doesn't matter what the date
is or the day as usual your sling and
dick and giving our [ __ ] them
brothers you understand me because
that's how we do it here
it's Friday I got a good night's sleep
I'm feeling tip top Magoo I went to the
Ice House last night
you can't play ass last last night I
love you with all my heart it was a
great night I've been trying to put
together in the wild where I could shoot
a special early next year it's a [ __ ]
night man you guys coming out for the
small tent makes my [ __ ] world who we
ended up having a great time Marty
Moreno was there James was there [ __ ]
the Agostino he don't show up you [ __ ]
up but you don't know what I cry over
spilt [ __ ] beans today's another day
your polish you dick your powdered your
balls and in the back of your mind you
know what nobody could [ __ ] stop you
we got some great wheels day we got the
tail end of the GMO and we got a potato
under the classic at 10 o'clock so they
have make another run for the [ __ ]
border to get my week prepared you
understand me but Joey what's with the
[ __ ] cheddar channel a some reefer
honest
that's what I'm talking about really
have my protein shaped I already had my
[ __ ] moon egg scrambled and now it's
listed either they're gonna suck your
dick today if I suck your dick next week
but eventually they're gonna so get that
and that's the attitude that's the
wisdom that's the state of mind you
leave the house with on a Friday Monday
Sunday what everything I know you know
what number two two things are gonna
happen today somebody's paying for me to
get up to get out here and deal with
these [ __ ] animals and number two
guess what you gotta justify your
[ __ ] existence on a daily I'm saying
it's over I don't give a [ __ ] what you
think on how you arrange you gotta
justify your existence daily you gotta
make sure you put your imprint on the
world I don't give you shoplift the
[ __ ] lighter you did something you
got to do something gotta get up off
that ass you got a right you got to
write down your goals do you're trying
to push ups with a vet and then you take
that ass to the whole pot of [ __ ]
daily and out that said it's that easy
let's finish this [ __ ] thing
you guys got me all excited about a
Friday like I told you
keep your eyes open that's the most
[ __ ] that's the most important then
keep guys [ __ ] on look I don't trust
nobody ever [ __ ] I don't trust no - if
it won't go quick
you gotta get a holiday you gotta get
the [ __ ] palette you understand me
you're still looking at your phone I got
a man make go [ __ ] yourself real men
don't look at [ __ ] Mendez all right
for you [ __ ] huh what do you
think about Floyd and Connor I don't
really don't give a [ __ ] to targets 20
stiff I'm dealing with delay come to me
August 25th local Joey you're dropping
on you but today is June 15 you got to
figure out how you gonna make it today
I don't let these [ __ ] know
that you're running things that you're
not [ __ ] around you can walk around
off up in there all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] eventually got lose that [ __ ] you
gotta become yourself all that it's
fabulous all that Kathy Griffin's [ __ ]
with all her friends they disappeared
because they're not as fabulous you
gotta get up you gotta swing take every
[ __ ] that'll do [ __ ] what you feel
I'm depressed go [ __ ] yourself you know
what depression is three black guys
laying there in Africa with flies all
over and waiting for their [ __ ] first
meal if that ain't what you're doing
stop with the [ __ ] depression there's
no depression they throwing your [ __ ]
mind get up stab a [ __ ] wash
your [ __ ] ass that's how it starts
you ever been the bad mood take a long
shower bang one out put the washcloth up
your muffler clean everything out you
feel [ __ ] like a hero he's like Abe
Lincoln
I'm will heat this one it's [ __ ] at
Friday when the 70s add this thing
Friday thank God it's Friday
listen in my world acknowledge Tuesday
every day I wake up I touch the ground I
kiss it the god and I say you [ __ ]
you gave me another day to impose my
will on these [ __ ] but that's
it beside that I'm happy if you're happy
I'm happy there's my best part of the
day when I get together with you savages
they're out there [ __ ] working and
busting your [ __ ] humps and now it's
time to bust your work and execute your
[ __ ] drinking time cuz why are you
digging that trench plate and keeps your
life waiting people like dig and try
just know it's the [ __ ] dream that
keeps you like this what do you think
should we do another bottle here what do
you think let's go another [ __ ] pipe
you can't walk on two legs let's do
another this is my favorite part of the
day and if you don't buddy you know
anything a bomb have no reason why I eat
[ __ ] I don't have you
[ __ ] around the world but you
me is my best partner today cuz I get to
talk to a family that God gave me
there's a complete different family we
got you guys we breathe for one another
you see some people to church back you
get my hug it's nothing crazy but anyway
let's go one more of respect for you
[ __ ] for the great week that
you had and for [ __ ] always throwing
me the love that you do I'm saying and I
love these [ __ ] back that's a
big word to say early in the morning
love I love that get your mind going a
good [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
primo he doesn't think of the Mexicans
before they [ __ ] jump the fence
tremendous you give to each other this
you'll be doing jumping jacks for days
and trust me I'm not dealt with jumping
over fences and [ __ ] like that
but anyway I love you [ __ ] with
all my heart
we got a podcast Sunday night we got a
podcast Monday night next we gotta tell
you why it's gonna be a hundred and
sixteen this [ __ ] next week so
we don't want to be out there they need
to thin out of tape this is not
happening
Wednesday night we have a surprise guest
and then [ __ ] Friday morning
I'll see you [ __ ] in strong
island [ __ ] right there right there
[ __ ] levee town across from to God my
man met Sara's jujitsu school I got four
shows and governess that's the place to
be next week I think there's one I leave
you alone because then you'd go and
giggle how are you [ __ ] boom box over
the fourth of July the following week
listen without you guys I got nothing
what would you remember
I make you laugh you listen to the
podcast we all scratches run each
other's back at the end of my what I'm
boarding a big picture is what you're
doing life in a big bag in a smart [ __ ]
I scratch your back you scratch mine and
worry whatever the [ __ ] you know life is
good family listen it's Friday be safe
be careful tonight watch your drinks
Cosby's nephews out there don't forget I
love you [ __ ] make it home in one
piece keep your eyes open and always
remember one thing in the back in mind
whether you speak Spanish on that oh
yeah didn't get my mic that I being a ho
a liar disciple get Pocatello legal you
and I'm your [ __ ] uncle today they
got a sucking dick whether your man a
woman they got a suckin dick my drove
them it's all value [ __ ] walking
through life scared like Rocky's [ __ ]
wife I'm saying that's it I love you
[ __ ] we're all mine I'll see
you next week and strong island
I'll see you [ __ ] next week at
this is not happening I'll see you
somewhere but the podcast is on Sunday
Father's Day and [ __ ] Monday I love
you [ __ ] thank you for being
the coolest [ __ ] family out of ahead
and thank you for laughing at my dumb
[ __ ] all right
I love your mother [ __ ] this day black
I'm a great weekend